le centre il est par les personnes qui
sont présentes sur sur la liste qui sont
issus de différents mouvements
centristes
pas plus tard qu'hier vois dans ma
permanence donc on a beaucoup échangé
avec jacqueline puis nos stades l'air
donc et référente départementale agir et
philippe benon et philippe et au pardon
à tous c'est extraordinaire puisqu'il
finit le nom de lui ne vous suis pas non
non et philippe alpy pardon c'est un
lapsus dont il me suis pas bon suite à
des échanges qu'on a pu qu'on a pu avoir
dernièrement il a fait un choix qui est
différent alors qu'il avait pu apporter
donc son soutien à mon égard c'est son
choix moi je n'en dirai pas plus par
rapport par rapport à cela donc philippe
alpy maire de fresnes qui étaient là
donc sur le référent référent agir
également qui m'accompagnent dans dans
la démarche
le groupe d'opposition de droite et du
centre ont pensé municipal de besançon
actuelle était par filles et si je veux
dire sur trois listes
comment vous l'expliquez est ce que vous
le regrettez je ne sais pas comment
comment l'expliquez après la politique
nationale a fait aussi que chaque
personne a pu prendre donc eu des
trajectoires des trajectoires
différentes
en tout cas ce qui concerne la liste qui
est porté en tout cas la clé chez deux
fils jacques grosperrin qui avec qui
nous sommes vraiment un travail constant
au quotidien nous avons gardé nos
convictions par rapport aux lignes que
nous portons sur sur le territoire
bisontin avec des projets phares que
nous avons déjà pu exposer durant
l'ensemble de ce mandat
néanmoins les personnes ont fait des
choix différents sur des jeux
d'appareils donc peut-être politique
aussi nationaux ça ça leur salaire
regarde
et eux de commenter c'est pas moi le
côté est-ce que alexandra corps d'yves à
vous rejoindre
or ce à écouter aujourd'hui c'est la
presse qui spéculent autour de cela je
crois qu'aujourd'hui chacun porte sa
campagne avec son accordiez porte sa
campagne à elle de pouvoir mener les
choses jusqu'au bout comme elle le
souhaite pareil pour les autres
candidats écoutez je crois que déjà il
ya une élection deux premiers tours à
pouvoir mener et apporter on verra après
l'avenir comment est ce la croix se
passer en tout cas chacun va pouvoir
mener campagne pour le premier tour et
je crois que c'est ça le plus important
aujourd'hui mais vous n'êtes pas contre
le fait qu'elle pourrait vous rejoindre
éventuellement je crois qu'aujourd'hui
le projet que l'on porte collectivement
et avec l'équipe besoins sont maintenant
c'est pour pouvoir redonner un dynamisme
et notre activité sur le territoire
bisontin toutes celles et ceux qui se
reconnaîtront qui se reconnaissent
aujourd'hui déjà dans cette dynamique-là
accompagne accompagne la démarche
après entre le premier et deuxième tours
c'est une autre élection qui se porte
il sera temps de voir un petit peu les
allées